وهشام احيلك اذا لما اعلنه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني عن وجود الدبابات الاسرائيليه
قرب مستشفى الامل وانه ايضا تم فقد
الاتصال مع الطواقم التابعه للهلال الاحمر
هناك ما
التفاصيل التفاصيل ان الجيش الاسرائيلي في
خانيونس وعلى مدار الساعات الماضيه ومنذ
عده ايام هو الجيش الاسرائيلي يقصف هذه
المناطق وحي الامل بالتحديد ومركز الهلال
الاحمر التابع للحي الامل وهو مركز بداخله
نازحون فلسطينيون هرب من قصف اسرائيلي في
مناطق مختلفه من المناطق الشرقيه لخاني وس
من مدينه غزه من شمال القطاع ولجوا الى
هذا المبنى التابع للهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني على اساس انه منطقه امنه رغم كل
ذلك قصفهم الجيش الاسرائيلي عده مرات خلال
الايام الماضيه خلال هذا اليوم الدبابات
الاسرائيليه تقدمت وخلال الساعات الماضيه
تقدمت لمسافات في مدينه خانيونس من الجهه
الجنوبيه تقدمت باتجاه الجهه الشماليه
وبالتالي باتت قريبه من
مركز مركز الهلال الاحمر مركز الامل وايضا
هو بجانبه مستشفى مستشفى الامل في حي
الامل حي الامل في قلب مدينه خانيونس
وبالتالي وصول الدبابات الى تلك المنطقه
بالتاكيد هو يشكل خطوره على هذه المنطقه
ويقطع طرق اساسيه ورئيسيه بالتاكيد من
مدينه خانيونس من المناطق الشرقيه الى
المناطق الغربيه بالتالي
وجود الطواقم الطبيه وجود طواقم الاسعاف
داخل مستشفى حي الامل وجود النازحين بكل
تاكيد هناك تهديد حقيقي عليهم من قبل
الدبابات الاسرائيليه التي توغلت
وبالتاكيد هناك تهديد حقيقي ايضا على
مستشفى ناصر الذي يتواجد في غير بعيد عن
مستشفى الامل كل هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
باتت الان تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه الدبابات
الاسرائيليه على ما يبدو اتجهت باتجاه
الشمال وايضا اتجهت باتجاه الغرب الدبابات
الاسرائيليه كانت تتموضع وتتمركز في
المناطق الجنوبيه لمستشفى ناصر اي في
منطقه قيزان النجار قيزان رشوان ايضا في
منطقه جورت اللوت البطن السمين وهذه كلها
مناطق متجاوره هي مناطق ملاصقه لبعضها
البعض وهي مناطق صغيره ربما مربعات سكنيه
وليست احياء بالكامل كي يفهم ان الوضع حي
كبير وبالتالي يتواجد فيه مناطق متعدده هي
مربعات سكنيه وتطلق عليها هذه المسميات
منذ زمن بعيد وبالتالي هذه المناطق المتلا
كانت تتواجد وتتمركز فيها وتتموضع
الدبابات الاسرائيليه توجهت باتجاه الشمال
باتجاه حي الامل وبالتالي الان من الممكن
ان يكون مركز حي الامل محاصر واتجهت
باتجاه الغرب باتجاه جامعه الاقصى ومستشفى
الخير وبالتالي بات النازحون في مستشفى في
جامعه الاقصى في خطر في ظل هذا التقدم